when it comes on to these agencies fbi
and cia right
where do they recruit from do they
recruit people from
these big yale schools do they go to you
know these big
ivy league schools and they're picking
people up from there and if they do
most of them are indoctrinated in one
side politically
but their job is to protect everybody
how often did you see in the cia or in
the fbi
the individual person's political
leanings influenced their decision
making in their job
i never really saw it i think that that
is a new trend uh part of the issue that
that i have is
you know our federal agencies need to be
headed by people that were part of that
agency
political appointees do not do well as
ahead of something that they don't
understand if you've never been in a car
meeting with a terrorist in a dark alley
how can you make decisions that that
affect me on the street
so i think the politicizers of of our
agency is is part of the problem you
know you have people that go in there
they're political appointees they owe
alliance
to whoever allowed them to go in there
rather than to those people that that
work for him or her
roger what do you think about what
richard said uh i think the vast
majority of rank and file fbi and cia
employees and agents are honest people
who have no politics the political
corruption is at the top of the of those
agencies um when
when fbi agents agents are raiding the
home of journalists to find out whether
they have a copy of joe biden's
daughter's diary i think that i think
that's crossing a line when fbi agents
are
arraigning the home of the number three
guy at the department of justice because
he held a different legal opinion than
others i don't think i don't think
that's i don't think that's appropriate
yeah you're talking about james o'keefe
when they yeah o'keefe in in this case
um
uh jeffrey
clark jeffrey the fbi director the doj
yeah i i wonder when i think about uh uh
by the way the two parties
can you pull up to see which which not
parties the two agencies which agency
does america trust more cia or fbi
i'm curious who's trusted more do you
guys know these stats or no
are you familiar like if if i were to
ask you and if i was outside so you're
not a part of it at all before they say
anything
do you trust the cia more do you trust
the fbi folks if you're listening as
well i'm curious comment below do you
trust the fbi more the cia more
what would you say
uh
just on the sheer fact that you've heard
the cia might have been responsible for
the kennedy association
just because of that i would lean
towards the fbi but i think they both
these days have
a damaged reputation well what is that
public uh holds positive views across 10
federal agencies departments number one
is what postal service favorable
seriously have they been to the post
office cdc
this is positive or unfavorable
seventy eight percent it's not this is
2018. okay
it's quite simple well then if you look
at this fbi ncaa is pretty much around
the same thing okay
i'd love to see what this is in 2022
because america the world has changed in
four years i think i actually think what
you would find is that
the public has a distrust of all
political institutions both parties
congress the fbi the cia the media
that's a fairly new development i think
that there is a fundamental distrust of
all of our institutions
by the american people
do you have some thoughts on this yeah i
do i really do you know that is the
reason why i wrote black ops because i
got so tired
of my agency being maligned in hollywood
we're not
jason bourne we're not american made
those things uh assassinating kennedy uh
you know the these are you know rumors
and stuff that goes out there part of
the political game
um you know the agency is put together
by
literally from all the classes we
recruit a lot from the military because
former military is has a lot more
diversity
um they have languages remember we the
united the cia we do not operate in the
united states
we're not allowed to operate in the
united states
um
so all our work is done overseas
so for that you need people that can fit
in in different
geographical areas without causing
attention because everything that we do
is
black ops under the shadow of darkness
or that we cannot afford for our mission
to be compromised rick you made a
comment earlier you said i'm
uncomfortable with folks who are not
from cia or fbi to be directors of the
sierra fbi
and if you've never sat there negotiated
with a terrorist you you don't know what
it's like to sit there negotiating with
a terrorist
that statement means that you have
you've sat there and negotiated with
terrorists yes i have
are you able to name some of the folks
you've sat down with and have
negotiations with no uh i could tell you
that i did recruit and uh no one's
watching this by the way
yeah i know you have such a short
follow-up no one's watching this content
but you were saying no the um the i did
recruit a terrorist in a latin american
country which i wasn't allowed to say in
the book
um but it was a member of a maoist
insurgency okay and i literally
recruited this guy under coercion
i had a police officer friend we
we busted him i was i had that you know
alias uh documentation with me
and um
you know the guy decided to cooperate
because we made him an offer they
couldn't refuse you know he would be in
in jail for the rest of his life and i
ran this guy for a good year and he gave
us some incredible information
um
so yeah i have done that and my point is
the fbi should be led
by a senior fbi individual that
understands those laws that understands
the culture
and understands the trials that that our
officers uh you know go through so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]